échanger rencontrer et expliqué c'était
l'heure de la rentrée pour les
différentes associations de l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
un premier rendez vous avec les
étudiants une prise de contact pour
encourager les entrants à s'investir
dans la vie du campus les étudiants ils
se rendent pas forcément compte que
maintenant on est plus au lycée
maintenant on est à la fac il ya des
associations pour qu'il fasse plein de
connaissances surtout avec des étudiants
de deux des différentes promotions
moi j'ai beaucoup d'amis que je garde
très précieusement encore aujourd'hui
notamment à travers l'associatif
mais pas que et voilà c'est une
expérience quoi on vit ici et ça fait
partie de la vie une vie associative qui
se développe progressivement à lui vs qu
25 ans après sa création l'université
compte désormais plus de 30 associations
actives sur ses différents sites
les associations sont là pour réaliser
des événements culturels mais aussi
créer des liens animé c'est surtout
aussi pour animer les campus rien que
sur saint quentin le territoire de saint
quentin on a douze associations qui sont
vraiment présente présent les étudiants
de l'éts et aussi comme issa qui reprend
cette année ses études d'hôtellerie et
de tourisme entre les études et le
travail la jeune femme espère ainsi
trouver une occupation pour se changer
les idées
il ya beaucoup de choses il ya des
mythes et hideux
des choses qu'on peut faire mais ce qui
m'a intéressé surtout ses jardins
partagés également le théâtre
pourquoi pas autre chose j'ai pas tout
fini je vais faire je vais faire le tour
d'autres forums associatifs sont prévues
pour répondre aux attentes des vingt
mille étudiants de l'ulb est ce qu
prochain rendez vous le jeudi 28
septembre sur le campus de versailles